welcome everybody good morning uh
and welcome to this latest meeting of
the trafford covered 19 public
engagement board thank you all for your
attendances i have apologies today from
councillors welton uh george devlin
and rebecca demaine are there any
further apologies at all
no are there any decorations of interest
in today's agenda items
thank you no
uh the minutes of the last meeting which
was held on the 1st of december can they
be taken as read please and as an
accurate record of that meeting
thank you
so we move on to the update on the
current kovid 19 situation in traffic
from helen and helen i think it's fair
to say we're remaining very difficult
times but i'll leave you to uh
to to talk to that thank you
thank you chair so
yeah we're in a different position than
we were um two weeks ago i would say so
where we currently are in trafford is
our rate is at
664 per 100 000 um of our population so
just to give an idea of what that means
um up to the 10th of december um for the
week before that
1578 of our residents tested positive
for covid so that's just to give it kind
of quantify that figure for you there um
we are the highest in greater manchester
now uh our rates are accelerating and
we're also the highest in the north west
and we're the 53rd highest local
authority nationally as well so that is
a concern
and there's a lot of movement around at
the moment in terms of rates but traffic
does consistently stay higher
um
in terms of the age groups that are most
affected our 0-14s are our highest age
group at the moment and so um
we're looking forward to the end of the
week when schools majority trafford
schools close on friday with a couple
going into next week and then the second
age group the highest rate is our 30 to
44 year olds and that is the group i
think when we think about that age group
are more likely to be mixing more likely
to be socializing as well and what we do
know is that our rates for our double
vaccinated are lowest in our under 40s
group as well so that's just something
we need to be mindful of
in terms of the age group that we are
most concerned about is obviously our
older population so our 60 pluses
and our rates
in that group did remain low but are now
starting to increase and that's that's
mainly due to a number of outbreaks that
um the ipc team and outbreak management
team are managing at the moment
so the rate for over 60s is now 135 per
100 000 but we are reasonably um low in
terms of their national rate so we were
120th nationally for that age group
yesterday but that is a group that we
are really really watching incredibly
carefully as you can imagine
um in terms of hospitalizations and
deaths our data we know up to the 9th of
december was stable so we were seeing
quite a steady number of people um in
terms of hospitalizations and deaths but
no upturn at the moment which again is
reassuring
in terms of where in trafford uh
timperley altringham and village area so
that kind of
south um central kind of pocket of
trafford is where we're seeing um the
highest numbers reporting through at the
moment but we are seeing an increase in
um
areas such as gorsul and longford which
again is communities that we
have concern about due to low vaccine
uptake houses are multiple occupation
and a number of other social economic
factors which um increase vulnerability
to communicable disease spread
so that's what we're looking at
currently
obviously uh omicron so trafford you
will have seen um we where i we did
identify a number of confirmed omicron
cases at the end of last week
and we were a point then really where
you could manage and look at the cases
really in detail and see what's
happening
so um the way we know we get daily lists
every day of the number of confirmed
cases the number of highly probable so
they're just waiting for the actual
confirmation from the lab
and then we get a list of possibles so
the way possibles are identified so this
is a question we're asked quite a lot is
people obviously go for a pcr test and
the results the pcr tests come through
on the result list we can see what's
known as an s gene failure so where
there is an s gene failure it's classed
as a possible
omicron or a different variant than the
ones that were unknown and not
circulating so we are managing a number
of those as well but um the approach now
has kind of been
that we consider all where there's an
increased spread or an outbreak feels
differently than it's considered to be
an omicron if we're not clear on the s
gene um failure at the moment but those
those results do come through really
really quickly and kirsty and the
outbreak team manage them really well
so in terms of that
we have seen possibles right across the
borough now um and that will be the same
in every gm borough and every borough
across um and and council across um
england so that's just to reassure you
there
so in terms of what we're doing let me
just go back to our outbreaks first
sorry before we talk about what we're
doing so um we are managing a number of
outbreaks in schools i would say the
highest activity is predominantly in our
primary schools at the moment
um but we are looking at a number of
secondary schools as well which kirsty
can uh elaborate on there
uh there are outbreaks in two care homes
um and we are also working with a number
of businesses as well in terms of
outbreaks at the other side the other
bit that we do with businesses obviously
is one of our advisors in the outbreak
club laura works very much on in terms
of supporting
events to go ahead safely so that's a
really important point that we do work
really proactively with our businesses
and our events teams across the borough
to ensure that um there are measures in
place to reduce risk and obviously laura
is very fully versed in plan b which
nigel will touch on later
the different the the changes we've had
in trafford then are obviously we know
that there's enhanced measures we've had
enhanced measures in our schools since
the beginning of october but now there's
a national measures that have kind of um
kind of taken over from those but they
are exactly what we put in place in
october um in trafford
we also have
encouraged strongly for household
contacts to lfd test
um since the beginning of october and
you will have seen that there was a
change in policy from um
very early tuesday morning around um
contacts contacts of people with any
variant of um covered to lfd tests for
seven days from contact so they no
longer need to isolate so that again is
something that we've had in place
um since the beginning of october and
then the other um enhanced measure that
has changed slightly
is around care home visiting so we even
paused
this care home visiting for under 16s
indoors so it was never kind of
never discouraged but it was about doing
it safely and outdoors so we've unpaused
that because of the recognition i think
around the need for families to see each
other at christmas especially when
they've got loved ones in care homes so
that's really important but what we have
done
our ipc team
infection prevention and control team
our care home commissioning team
residential care home commissioning team
and outbreak team have been working
really closely with our care homes who
are doing a phenomenal job we have to
acknowledge the stress and pressure that
is on the care home system at the moment
to ensure safe visiting over christmas
so families can see their families
residents can see their families enjoy
the christmas spirit but to do it as
safely as possible and that is around
looking at different
approaches to visiting so whether it is
back into pods or other safe kind of
environments but also ensuring that we
implement the national guidance which is
around um having um a clear list of who
can visit and who can't visit as well so
we are implementing that locally
um
and i suppose the other the other point
i touched on briefly is around the lfd
testing so you will know up until it was
it was quite um
quite a
difficult two weeks challenging two
weeks where um possible contacts
contacts of possible cases or confirmed
cases of omicron were individually
contacted and asked to isolate for ten
days
that changed um monday night so now um
people who are contacts
of any variant
do not need to isolate unless they are
unvaccinated as an adult so if you don't
have your two vaccinations you still
have to isolate and you still have to go
for your pcr if you are fully vaccinated
or your age between 5 and 18 the advice
is to lfd test for seven days
um
but obviously it's just just a kind of
um an issue that we've seen this week is
around um
access to lfd tests which ben will talk
about further so they are available that
we've been told that there's no concern
about accessibility to lfd tests but
monday i think was a very pressured day
a lot of people reacted to the news on
sunday and tried to access the national
portal the other aspect the other bit we
need to be mindful of lfd tests so it's
about people who are contacts
um
testing daily but also in terms of plan
b if people want to go out and about
over christmas um lfd is part of the
plan b approach if you're not fully
vaccinated so there's pressures on the
lfd system there but um we would highly
absolutely
you know encourage people to lfd test
when they're going out and about at the
moment it's really really important and
any symptoms obviously you would go for
your pcr test
the other big news which i'm going to
leave to mark angela to cover and it's
huge is around the vaccine program
so this is i would say
for us it's kind of a program once in a
generation program we hope but it's a
huge push in the next 12 days and
colleagues across our healthcare system
our ccg and the coverage response team
are working exceptionally hard to ensure
that everybody
who needs a booster vaccine by the 31st
of january
december will be able to book or access
it so i'll leave mark and jilla to talk
about that but as you can see a huge
amount has happened since the last time
we met
so please do ask any of our colleagues
any questions that you might have or any
points of clarity if you can't answer
them
uh in this forum we will always take
them away and and respond to you as soon
as we can so thank you chair
thank you helen and before i open up the
questions know khan wants to come in
can i just ask
if somebody takes a pcr test will they
be told as part of that result what the
variant is can they identify themselves
whether it's army crime or very
b or whatever
um so up until the beginning of the week
um yes so they would be told by nhs test
and trace that they were a possible or a
confirmed omicron
um i'm going to have to it is kirsty on
the call just to confirm whether that is
still happening kirsty because i think
the important thing to note is the
volume of um cases coming through is
obviously increased significantly but
kirsty can you answer that question
i can yeah so as of yesterday um uxo uk
health security agency released a
statement
um saying that it's expected that
omicron will become the dominant variant
within the next few days so in view of
this
um omicron will be managed in line with
delta so it's very unlikely that
somebody would never be told what
variant it is because it's it's more or
less the same in terms of numbers
thank you kirsty that that's that's very
clear that thank you i've got a question
from khan and then councillor acting to
follow the last two two basic uh issues
one is
now that we have no reckless countries
and if people are coming from those
countries
uh how
are we going to trust people that
they're going to
maintain their own
uh quarantine and
uh
conclude the tests uh how how are those
people being followed up
and secondly
uh
we did hear boris johnson talking about
a plan c
now do you know and he would plan c what
it is if there is if there is
one so if i um talk through the plan c
i'm going to look again to kirsty who is
our um expert this week because it's
just been such a fast flowing moment
around travel but um in terms of plan c
we don't know the details of plan c at
the moment so we can only assume
um so it might be a further escalation
in terms of the vaccine passport
approach perhaps or the other the only
other area that i could think of as
would be and obviously this is this is
just
making assumptions this isn't evidence
at all and my opinion
would be about um bringing back in
isolation
again but obviously we'd have to wait
for confirmation and we've had no um
kind of confirmation at all around the
plan c at the moment so we're just
purely working to the guidance that we
know and um and looking at plan b as
well so i wouldn't want to kind of
second guess what they're thinking at
the moment thanks khan but kirsty could
you comment on travel at all i know it's
a very difficult one in terms of
ensuring people quarantine
yep so obviously at the minute the um
rule still is that people have to have a
day two test regardless of their
vaccination status and return from
travel and regardless of what country
that they have returned from whether
that was a country put on
the list for high-risk omicron variant
or just any kind of european country so
day two tests are returned from travel
and that's monitored by the national
team so they will follow people up to
make sure that they are isolating on
that return from travel and that they
have done that test
and just come back on that one um
we know uh for some cases in the past
where
people have actually left their mobiles
at home
and and gone around
visiting people and so on and that has
not been very very successful i don't
know how
how that is being managed
i guess if a case comes to us locally
what we do do if we feel that there's
been a breach in isolation then we do
report that to the relevant authorities
and obviously they can be subject to a
fine um and you know that that law
enforcement around breach in isolation
so locally we do follow those up where
there is a breach or we're aware of a
breach and
and the national team may also pass them
on to us but it's only where we know
about them cases and it's difficult
because obviously some will slip through
the net
thank you
um
yeah thanks chair um yeah i i noted that
uh gauss hill and longford rates of
infection are high
and the uptake of vaccine is low in that
area so i suppose what i'm asking is
um
you know how are we dealing with that uh
are there enough vaccination points um
i know there's quite intense activity
deeper into old trafford um
but i don't know about ghost hill
whether there has been that kind of
um action taken in in that area
thanks
acting so i'm going to ask my colleague
jiller to come in and she's our public
health lead for vaccinations but just to
reassure you that as a vaccination
operational team we do
very much focus on the areas with low
uptake and consider them really
carefully in terms of what action we can
take and we did um
introduce a programme through our
primary care around ringing patients
directly to encourage them to um attend
for the vaccine but i'm going to hand
over now to jill he'll be able to give
you more detail thanks jiller
thank you yeah so i can reassure you
that we have excellent coverage across
the whole borough in terms of our
provision of vaccine clinics so there
are no cold spots people can easily
access the vaccine in all communities
across trafford
in terms of that targeted work that
helen mentioned that was very
geographically focused in the clifford
ward
with some
some additional activity in partington
so that didn't cover gauss hill but the
community engagement team in general
do cover the whole borough and they do
work to promote
the vaccine in all areas and they've
made really good links with all the
community hubs and key
community organizations and we have a
good spread of community champions
across our neighborhoods who really help
us to reach into communities with those
messages around the vaccine
so
certainly that activity alongside the
comms and marketing work that we do
should be reaching those communities and
as i say the access to clinics is good
too
can you tell me where the vaccination
points the nearest vaccination points
are in the center of gas hill
and longford
because you know access is really
important in terms of
you know encouraging people to
uh get vaccinated so i'd like to know
where where they are
they could be improved that access
absolutely i can provide you with that i
don't have it immediately to hand but if
it's okay i'll send it to you after the
meeting okay thank you
thank you chiller um councillor
blackburn
thank you could i just ask can we be
reassured that the chemists throughout
the borough have adequate supplies of
the lateral flow tests
ben could you answer that question i'm
just going to say yeah i'll jump in here
um
that's council blackburn so at the
moment we do know um that we had some
reports anyway of some pharmacies not
having um enough supply currently of
those electrical flow tests
um
it may be that some pharmacies have
chosen not to continue with this given
how busy they've been um but in general
we've been um assured by the national
team yesterday that there is enough
capacity in the system in terms of those
like flow tests to be sent out to
pharmacies and they are continuing to
send them out all the time so but we do
recognize that we have heard reports of
issues around pharmacies i will add and
i was going to bring this up in my
update later that we also have a number
of community collect sites that we set
up ourselves so we've got four libraries
um and three of our community hubs that
also go and hand that ladder flow test
we know there is not a shortage there
and one of the benefits of using those
community collect sites is that you
don't need to have a code to go and pick
up those tests whereas you do at the
pharmacies um so i'm not saying it's a
perfect solution but we have at least
you know took steps to make sure that
the residents are still able to access
watch your flow test if they're not able
to from those pharmacies
thank you
thank you ben uh councillor new gross
thank you uh i just wanted to it's
one question and uh one statement um i'm
aware that there are pcr delays uh i'm
aware of someone that took a pcr uh
thursday morning of last week no result
yet
um
and i i hope that that is uh isolated
but
if other people are hearing this uh it
would be nice to know if there's some
sort of trend that they might have the
system there
also on transport
last wednesday was the uh a united home
game
the tram
probably two inches apart was uh was the
distance of people on that tram
also
delay cancelled trains over the national
trains over the weekend
led to 75 services being cancelled the
remaining services also rammed
we are setting up conditions here to to
enabled spread so i don't know what we
can do but we need to be aware that this
is happening and it's
regionally in our neighborhood
that's it
could i comment on that
so i'm part of the um greater manchester
compliance cell council new gross show i
will take that back to you i know that
tfgm are working exceptionally hard in
terms of compliance on the tram system
um but i'll take that back just to
ensure that it's heard because that is a
really important obviously the message
at the moment is around
working from home so we would hope the
daily commute is looking safer
um but obviously whilst the event events
continue but i know there are
the sags which are the meetings that
come together to ensure safety of large
events for example do seriously consider
the safety of travel
as well so it is you know where it it
people are working incredibly hard to
try to ensure that public transport is
safe at the moment
thanks helen uh council accordingly
uh thanks chair um
yeah i was i just on that last note now
i was at the match last night and the
tram was absolutely rammed at uh
cornbrook absolutely random couldn't get
i think another person on
i i mean i couldn't get on it and there
was real delays and uh all the sort of
altering of trams were
absolutely packed to the gills two
inches is uh way
more than was allowed on that tram it
was total sardines so and hardly anybody
wearing mass by the way um
so yeah it's it's just one of those
things um
in terms of the rate of progress i mean
we don't i mean we don't know
the
extent of omicron but we can guess
largely that
by the rates that um that are increasing
and doubling and we trafford as far as i
can see
the the graph is going
exponentially upwards almost
more than doubling i think i think the
rate of increase here
and across manchester is uh
greater than most places
um
that said the news you gave on
hospitalizations
is good and they're not going up uh yet
um
it seems to me
if anything
i see new uses across north west seems
to be sort of nudging slightly down as
far as the uh
the national figures are concerned and
that are given for the north west
um
so there is optimism
um but what worries me um
with this rate of increase we'll quickly
find
that key services
can't operate
um
you know the post is uh way off but it's
it's not so much the post it's it's
other areas of work that would worry me
and i don't i don't know where where
we
at what point do we say we can no longer
afford to isolate for
10 days we can't afford those staff not
to come in
that have got
that are asymptomatic
um if they're well enough to work
and they're needed on the front line as
opposed to working from home
where does that happen
um
and i think that's probably where we're
heading in a few weeks that will be less
about isolation and more about managing
the workforce is better so i i just like
you know
in some ways i
in some ways i'm not totally um
panicking over this because
the the symptomatic
uh aspects are
seem to be a lot less with this omnica
omnivarus but um
omicron yeah but and i suppose my worry
is
are we able to liaise with employers and
what have you and are they gearing up
for how they can cope
as this grows
thank you thank you
would you like me to come in
so there's a couple of points there
really and i suppose to start at the
beginning is at the moment with omicron
they're still building the evidence base
so although it looks
reassuring we aren't clear
of um
a number of issues around omicron so for
those people who aren't vaccinated for
example when it's understanding the
impact of the new variant on that that
group in our population so at the moment
we're still in this kind of
precautionary phase so it is waiting and
understanding what the impact of omicron
is um and hopefully we should know that
uh in the next few weeks there's a huge
amount of work happening with uxa the uk
health security agency and the
government to understand the impact of
the virus so at the moment we all have
to be really cautious because um we need
to be able to uh reduce the transmission
where possible until you know while we
understand this virus a bit more
so um
you know jillo is going to talk to us
very much in a moment around the boost
of the booster program but as a
as a resident as residents and as a
population we need to really stick by
what we know so far that works and that
is around social distancing face
covering where possible reducing your
mixing and i know it's incredibly
difficult at this time of year but just
kind of just think through do you need
to do that tonight if you're going to go
and see somebody else tomorrow and just
kind of manage that kind of a bit more
and if you are then do lfd test but face
covering social distancing symptom
awareness i would say as well that if
you do feel unwell um or you present
with any of the symptoms then do go for
a pcr test um because the boost in the
you know we need to get the booster
program rolling get everybody boosted
but also just recognition that the
vaccine can't work on its own so it's
just about those things really
in terms of businesses um
this at the moment links again very much
into understanding the impact of omicron
and the impact of what that has in terms
of how seriously people become unwell
and then um how fast it spreads and we
have seen and kirsty will
attest to this we have seen a number of
settings this week that have been really
badly impacted by um by illness
spreading through but but you know at
the moment it appears to be a mild
illness but again just to reiterate it's
about understanding that and having the
evidence base behind the impacts of the
virus
so what we have done as a council is um
to ask ourselves to look at business
continuity so we can continue to deliver
to our residents which is a really
important point and that's one thing we
would very much impress on any
businesses across trafford and we do
communicate out to our businesses um
with some key messages around keeping a
covered secure workplace but also to
consider business continuity as well
well again while we try to understand
the um virus and the final bit on my um
list really is just to um
[Music]
kind of ask
and ask for our counselors because you
are you know you have the ear of your um
residence and they will listen and and
you know you have social media and you
have a presence in your community and we
would just really ask for support from
you at the moment um counselor acton you
know if you're representing clifford
ward if you could support us with
messages out around vaccination that
would be hugely appreciated um and the
same to all your counsellor colleagues
as well anything you can do to support
us at this point would be really really
appreciated and i know that you do um
anyway but it's just as we go into the
christmas period
so i think they're the the four points i
just wanted to talk about then thank you
thank you thank you thank you helen i
don't see any further questions uh i
just want to change the agenda around
and ask nigel smith to come in on
community of buzzers i know he's got to
go at 11 o'clock but this isn't uh we've
brought this back onto the agenda this
time in light of the the new uh
regulations that have have come in so if
i hand over to nigel um and that means
you can get away in time nigel because
there might be some questions for you as
well thank you
thank you chair for that so uh yes what
i wanted to do today was to just give an
update first of all in relation to
well from the work of regulatory
services first of all in relation to
phase coverings to give an overview of
what the requirements are in various
enforcement roles and the action that
we've taken and also i wanted to give an
update on covid
passes as well
so in terms of the wearing of face
coverings i'm sure you're all aware new
regulations came into force at the end
of november
uh in relation to the wearing a face
coverings so
this legislation requires members of the
public and staff to wear face coverings
in public facing areas in many indoor
places and when using public transport
uh
these premises that it applies to must
also display a notice stating the
requirement for face coverings to be
worn
so initially when this these regulations
were brought in it covered
retail
premises such as takeaways without
seating hairdressers beauticians
premises such as that
and then within a few days it was
actually extended
so the face masks now need to be worn in
most public indoor venues
that was from the 10th of december so
the new premises that were brought in
included cinemas theaters places of
worship
so like i say it's most
indoor venues
where the public go to now need to wear
face masks um
there are certain settings that are not
required though and that is primarily
the hospitality sector where food and
drink is consumed such as pubs cafes
restaurants
or also where people might be doing
exercise such as in gyms or dancing such
as nightclubs so there's a full list of
the businesses that
it applies to that is on the government
website but
that's an overview of where it applies
to
some people are exempt obviously
children that are under 11 don't need to
wear the base coverings and anyone with
health condition disability which means
they can't wear a health covering base
covering as well
so in terms of enforcement um the key
thing i just need to explain is that the
requirement on individuals whether
that's members of the public or for
employees to wear the face coverings is
enforced by the police
so the local authority cannot legally
enforce people to wear face coverings
and businesses cannot as well so it is
down to the police alone to enforce that
measure
um so the local authorities do have
enforcement responsibilities but only in
two very distinct areas so the main one
that we have enforcement responsibility
for
is in relation to the requirement for
businesses to display a notice
displaying the face coverings must be
worn and so every business must do that
or take other steps such as you know
making announcements in the shop for
example to say that encouraging people
to wear face coverings
so that's the main role that we have
there's also another power that we have
which is that if a business prevents
anyone from wearing a phase covering
which is quite an unusual power but what
i think this relates to is that if a
business
was not letting for example an employee
wear a face covering where they wanted
to
then that's where we would have a power
to to take action there but the main
responsibility we have is around the
requirement for businesses to display
the notice
we have also had direction from
government on the important approach
they want us to take and it is very much
that they want us to encourage
businesses and individuals to comply
and that businesses understand what they
need to do as opposed to you know
proactive enforcement
and that you know if we were going to
take enforcement action it is very much
that it's necessary and proportionate so
ultimately if we did need to take action
against the business
or not displaying a notice then we could
issue a fixed penalty notice
so
excuse me
so the actions that we've taken
as i said it's very much around
encouraging businesses to comply
uh the comms team i know have been
sending out regular messaging via and
will continue to send out regular
messaging via social media and there's a
comms pack which they have been provided
from government to use
we have spoken to the police
and they're taking the the four e's
approach which you're probably familiar
with which is engage educate encourage
and then enforcement as the last resort
so if we do get complaints relating to
the individuals
uh then we can refer those to to gmp
i've got to say
the complaints that we've had are very
very low in number so far
um but we have said to the police even
though they've got the primary
enforcement powers here that if they are
having repeat problems with businesses
that
would be willing to support them
with joint visits
uh what we have done is in relation to
our specific role relating to displays
of signage we have sent letters out to
uh various sectors
particularly those where they might be
less familiar that they need to display
the signage so for example hairdressers
tattooists takeaways there to cinemas
when they were added so we've sent out
emails to those where we've got the
contact details and also a link with a
poster that they can download
the licensing team have also sent an
email out to the taxi trade
but drivers and operators are they are
aware of what their what they are
required to do
we've got a poster a template poster
which the comms team have printed off a
large number of those for us for staff
to hand out
so the environmental health team have
been in contact with some of the larger
businesses such as the trafford center
stratford-mall and also the inclusive
economy team have distributed the letter
to
businesses such as altering bids
eden square etcetera to share with their
tenants and members
there's also going to be a piece in the
business bulletin going out uh i think
in the next few days on this
uh also we've got a couple of staff
which helen has uh allowed us to have
from the covert team
uh a one day a week to do some proactive
work in town centres hot spot areas
so this is not an enforcement role as
such but it's about giving advice
talking to businesses checking if
they've got the lotus displayed and if
not handing out the poster
and they did that initial some issue
visits in the north of the borough last
wednesday
um did a number of visits majority of
businesses they spoke to were very
responsive handed out a number of
posters where they weren't displaying
them and they're going to be out again
today
doing further visits
so that's an overview in terms of face
coverings and i also wanted to uh
briefly mention the kobe pass
requirements
so um with the announcement of the move
to plan b the nhs kovid pass is now
mandatory in certain specific settings
from today
so the regulations and guidance has only
been out for a day or two so it's all
very new we're all just getting uh
familiar with it but essentially
if you are age 18 or over to get into
certain venues you must have proof of uh
that you're vaccinated with the two but
two doses of an approved vaccine unless
it's the single dose uh jansen vaccine
or that you're taking a pcr or rapid
lateral flow within the last 48 hours or
there's exemptions for medical or that
you're taking part in the trial so the
main way that you would do this is
through you're showing your covered past
to show that you're vaccinated or that
you have had a negative test in the last
48 hours
so the venues where this applies to um
should have a responsible person who is
responsible for making sure that these
rules are followed
and the the venues
it is a very specific limited number of
venues where this will apply to
uh so those are things like nightclubs
dance halls uh other late night dance
venues so venues where they've got
a license to sell alcohol beyond one
o'clock
where they've got a dance floor and
where there's live music and dancing
then indoor events with 500 or more
attendees but that's where only those uh
attendees are likely to
stand or move around such as music
venues
or outdoor events with 4 000 or more
attendees where again people are likely
to move or stand around
or any events with more than 10 000
attendees
so we did some uh initial work to
identify where we thought this would
apply and there was an initial around
about 26 premises which we thought
so sports clubs large event venues
nightclubs which we thought this might
apply to
so we did send out an initial letter to
these businesses before uh plan b was
announced in anticipation that an
announcement was coming
and then when plan b was announced we
sent out a further letter to those
businesses uh confirming what was what
the requirements were
we've subsequently identified a smaller
number of businesses you know another
four or five businesses which might also
be within scope which we're also
contacting so
following sending out these letters the
environmental health team are also
making contact with every single one of
these businesses
this week to check they've got
procedures in place uh to implement the
kobe pass checks
and uh with some of these venues we've
already been working with some of them
for the last few weeks actually talking
to them about what measures they should
have in place and to make sure they've
got
the necessary measures they need to have
there are various
exemptions that apply and the
regulations are quite complicated so and
there will be specific queries no doubt
that we'll get from various businesses
as and when they arise so
the enforcement approach that we're
looking to take is very much one of
making sure that businesses understand
what they need to do we want to work
with businesses and hopefully they will
all comply i'm sure they will but should
it be necessary there are various
enforcement tools that we've got
so we can issue a coronavirus
improvement notice on businesses and if
they fail to comply with that then we've
got other powers
uh restriction notices which enable us
to close all our part of a business or
venue or event if that was necessary and
ultimately also take legal action in
terms of prosecutions or fixed penalty
notices so we have got tools if we need
them to make sure that businesses comply
but as i say we're very much
wanting to work with businesses being on
the front foot contacted businesses and
speaking to them all this week as well
to make sure they all understand and
know what they're doing so
that was uh just the update i wanted to
give share but happy to take any any
questions thank you nigel there is a
question going to come from councillor
blackburn but before she asks it am i
right in thinking then that if you want
to go to the trafford center they're
going to have to have a pursuit they're
going to have to you have to show kobe
passport to enter into that area
into the traffic center no
no they're not because no surprise no
only only so if you go back to the it's
only down to those specific type of
venues so if there was somewhere at the
trafford center that was you know open
beyond one o'clock and had dancing that
kind of issue or if there was a large
event so like event city something like
event would be captured if they had a
larger type event going on but uh the
traffic tend to know because it's just a
retail
retail venue so they are not captured by
the kobe pass a retail venue attacking
thousands and thousands of people but
there we go thank you council blackburn
and then i just wanted to ask about the
practicality of checking all these
passes at premier league football
grounds
how
how on earth are they going to check 40
odd thousand passes
pretty much
yeah so within within the regulations
and the guidance
so
for something like um a nightclub it is
expected that they will
check that everybody has got the covet
pass but there are some specific uh
um
requirements within the within the
guidance and the regulations that
in specific circumstances where and and
and football is one of those so where
they're expecting a large number of
people to all turn up at the same time
where if you are wanting to check
everybody that could cause further
problems because you could get cues
forming you know outside of the venues
it's going to cause potential safety
issues so when you've got um
when you've got this specific
circumstances then there is the
requirement that
um so not requirement but there is a
part there
there is the option for those businesses
to do spot checks
so what what those businesses need to do
is they uh so a sports club what they
will need to do is is come up with a
risk assessment
where they decide how many of the uh
people attending they're going to check
so for example 20
of people they can attend on any
particular day how they're going to do
that
they send that risk assessment to us as
a local authority we check it and if
we're happy with it and that's the
approach they can take so i'm expecting
that probably
for large sports venues such as premier
league games that that's the approach
that will be taken so it'll be perhaps
20
something like that on any given match
rather than trying to do absolutely
everybody
so yeah there is that approach that they
can take for something like that but for
the smaller venues then it's expected
that everybody would be checked
okay thank you
thank you thank you that uh clearly
council blackburn the 40 000 you're
referring to would have been a city game
not a united game
um
the um
i will just add here that of course
we've all got if you've got the nhs app
you've you've got your kobe pass on
there you can upload if you've got an
apple phone you can up that load for
quick checking onto your apple wallet
and the digital age nigel as well um
if you're going to united most of the
tickets now for season ticket orders are
digital anyway they're on your phone so
it's just a question of the someone
presenting the phone show the ticket and
then show their apple wallet or or or
the pass that way so
but i think that the approach is very
sensible and
i don't see helen you've got your hand
up helen you want to come in
yeah i just wanted to say that um the
public health team has been working
closely with nigel's team and our sports
grounds and we're assured by the
approach that they're taking
so the um you know the message out to
fans is that you will be checked when
you attend and that's that's the message
it's very important that any fans who
are coming to a match come prepared to
share their vaccine passport otherwise
they will be turned away and i see
council courtney's put in the chat city
weren't checking but they were certainly
scoring goals last night mike weren't
they
um
i don't see any further questions at all
uh for you nigel kind of thank you for
that input and um
i think it's very very thorough and very
reassuring what you've had to say
so we're returning to the agenda
can i bring in ben wilmot on mass
testing please
morning chair thank you very much so um
quite a few updates today then on
testing um first of all just to quickly
reiterate the changes that helen
mentioned before um that daily later
flow testing for close contacts off
covered has been introduced for those
that will vaccinate their age five to
eighteen and they're asked to take a
intellectual flow tests for seven
consecutive days
now as a result of this and obviously
the the increase in code rates um as
hell mentioned you know we've seen the
last couple of days there have been
times where people haven't been able to
order lateral flow tests to their house
um this isn't because they've run out of
tests this is because there's a cap each
day on deliveries and demand has has
increased due to those rules changes and
we also know in terms of other issues um
again as council blackburn um talked
about before that there have been some
issues when it comes to picking up tests
from pharmacies either because of stock
or because of the requirement to go and
have a code
so in terms of some of the kind of at
least updates or solutions
for those problems in terms of
deliveries we are told there's more
capacity to deliver tests that's been
put into the system and that should
start to appear in the next couple of
days which is promising
and when it comes to farmers these
pharmacies have been reminded now that
they don't need to go and collect the
code to give out tests so obviously
they're asked to do so but it's not a
requirement to have that code and they
have been reminded of that um by greater
manchester um and one of the pharmacy
associations
um otherwise as i also mentioned before
in terms of those community collect
sites um we have got um seven sites in
trafford um either libraries or
community hubs where you do not need a
code to go and pick up tests you can
just turn up
and those sites currently do have stock
and then finally we have our own testing
team so we've
got some kits available basically that
we'll use either for outbreaks or to
support kind of our core staff that are
going out to care homes for instance
just to make sure that everyone that
really does need it is able to access
those lots of flow tests so we have got
um yeah support mechanisms in place
which is positive
um other updates on social care so for
care homes the department health
association has asked homes to now take
three lateral flow tests each week
rather than two as well as that weekly
pcr tests
um again just for reassurance we do have
more than enough um of the type of tests
used by care homes to support them so
that's again um very positive that we're
not going to announce from that
perspective and then in terms of the
testing team's ongoing work so we tested
at prime school um on monday 112 tests
carried out that was again
parents carers staff and pupils all
because it was an outbreak we're just
trying to find as many asymptomatic
people as possible in the past couple
weeks we've carried out 299 tests using
mobile test units and handed out 520 pcr
t tests so a really large number there
all at key settings such as schools
early years
and social care settings um as well as
that we've also handed out um almost one
and a half thousand watch for flow home
tests in the past couple weeks again to
residents into businesses and other key
settings so really really pushing that
test in as much as possible um in terms
of the stats that's been born out so we
have continuously been the highest um
area when it comes to testing
um and we're still the highest area in
greater manchester when it comes to
testing
um so i suppose in terms of those key
messages as as helen says we know it's
frustrated you can't get all the tests
at the moment but it should get easier
over the coming days and there are
different routes available um so please
get tested before you go and mix with
other people i think that's the really
key thing we're trying to drive home um
and just um in terms of the point um
before made by councillor new gross yes
we do know at the moment there are
issues around pcr testing that isn't
about access to pcr tests it's about the
lab capacity to go and process those
tests so again we're told that lab
capacity will be will be increased as
time goes on and but just to make you
aware of that but nonetheless um you
will also get those pci results back so
please please please continue if you've
got any symptoms go and get yourself a
pcr test
and that's yeah the key messages for me
at the moment thanks so much chair
thank you ben are there any questions
for ben at all
i don't see any ben so so thank you um
move on to contact tracing and outbreak
management kirsty welcome kirsty
thank you chair apologies if my update
is a little bit of a repeat of what
helen and or ben has already said um but
obviously they all tie in together at
the minute
and so in terms of contact tracing
within our complex settings we
are incredibly busy
across our schools
just supporting them with lots of
inquiries and queries in relation to the
guidance changes and obviously
increasing in cases
we still continue to see um big
difference in case numbers across our
primary and secondary schools
in line with what the data is showing
those really so the younger age groups
we're seeing lots more of them test
positive
and we have a number of primary schools
with outbreaks
um
we're not seeing the same number of
outbreaks in our high school so that
seems to be manageable and under control
at the minute
the high rates in our schools mirror
what we're seeing in the community um
areas such as timperley work where the
rate is high and that's reflected across
the schools
and
so yeah lots of inquiries from schools
and we just continue to support them
with it
and
we are seeing increasing cases within
our workplace settings and as helen
mentioned we're working with them in
managing those outbreaks as well
and a couple of homemade breaks as helen
has already mentioned
and i know i summarised earlier that
obviously it's expected that omicron
will become the dominant variant within
within a few days
so in view of that
and the introduction of daily testing to
manage that
um
our focus in trafford will remain on
focusing on high risk settings without
breaks in them
in terms of local contact racing so
that's case is not reached by the
national team again um the the daily
case numbers that are coming through to
us in trafford locally at very very high
so
um we have a very small team managing
these cases
so we are taking a bit of a hit on our
performance rate whereas the
two weeks ago it was the top across gm
for our local contact racing just to the
sheer number of cases that are coming
through from the national team we will
see a little bit of a dip in that
so i guess a plea to our residents it
really is to please engage in contact
tracing if you're contacted by the
national or the local team
there's various ways to complete contact
tracing you can do it online you can do
it over the phone and our contact races
will fully support you if you're having
any difficulty um with that and and
there's various ways that we we can
contact you whether that be through text
message or email
and then i just wanted to
very quickly um summarize those key
guidance changes
so after a week or so of guidance
clarity and national changes
the actions that the key actions
required whether omicron or not are all
the same so it's if you're positive if
you have a positive pcr isolate for the
full 10 days
as a contact complete daily lfd testing
for seven days and that applies to
anyone age five and over even if you're
vaccinated
um under fives do not need to isolate
and do not need to daily lfd test
but we're encouraging them to have a pcr
if there's a positive case within the
household and the key is unvaccinated
people over age 18 and 6 months need to
continue to isolate as a close contact
the only difference to that is health
and social care staff and so fully
vaccinated staff and care home residents
and they're required to have a pcr taken
after a contact has occurred and staff
and residents should isolate and stay
off work until they have a negative
result
and their daily lateral flow testing
should continue for 10 days thereafter
so that's the update from media thank
you
thanks kirsten can i just ask you uh
before i open the questions about
support for those that financial support
for those that need to isolate and we
still got
this in place
we have yeah sorry i didn't cover that
um so anybody who has requested um
self-isolation support they are
contacted um and any support that they
have requested will be given obviously
there's a little bit more flexibility as
well in terms of those that can claim
the 500 pound support payment because we
had that period where people did need to
isolate as a close contact until the
guidance changed on tuesday so there
will be some people that fall into that
category where other types of evidence
will be accepted to claim that payment
thank you very much for
for that courtesy i don't see any
questions for you
you're on mute councillor freeman
pardon can we then move up there we'll
move on to mass vaccination
bring mark jarvis but mark can you
possibly
confirm to us
what walk-in pop-up clinics we've got
for booster jobs in trafford this week i
mean the pm said they'll be popping up
like christmas trees but i know my son
this morning has had his booster at lark
hill by booking it through the web yet
there were people queuing up at lark
hill who hadn't got appointments so
perhaps we can cover that as part of
your presentation as well thank you
certainly i'll do my best
um
so
the levels we've vaccinated seem a bit
relevant today although we we've got to
about 80
double vaccinated and i i'm quite happy
to provide any more detailed figures on
that if if they're required
um
the
the more important figure
is at the start of yesterday we had 67
000 people who were going to be eligible
for a booster
by the end of december
so if we hope to deliver that without
spoiling christmas day and boxing day
for people
we're aiming to vaccinate 4 000 people a
day across trafford
um
and
we are in the process of finalizing the
plans to actually achieve that
so we have pharmacy sites across
trafford
um
1881 in ermstan was on
manchester radio yesterday
quite successfully
vaccinating over 500 people a lot of
whom were walk-ins
and the lark hill center you've just
mentioned also is a very active site
which is taking
um some walk-ins as well as
the the booked appointments
the majority of our
vaccinations have been delivered by
primary care networks gp practices
up until this point in time
and they are in the process of ramping
up their
capacity to deliver that
we think in trafford that we've got the
capacity to deliver those on existing
sites
so we're unlikely to have too many
pop-up sites just appearing
we're aiming to actually use tried and
tested venues with tried and tested
teams just over a broader period of
hours
and
that's being finalized today and the
communication about exactly where we'll
be open when
how to book those
and
um you know where you might be able to
attend for a walk-in will be shared
today
across all the media outlets through the
system so we'll quite happily share it
with
everybody who's present in this meeting
as well as
going far more public with that
information as soon as it's available
the reason that's today
is because late last night
um or late yesterday afternoon there was
the
confirmation that the 15 minute wait is
no longer necessary
for
um
the
booster vaccinations the risks of
vaccinations not suiting people
is is mainly in their first and second
jabs
so
the removal
as some of you may know if you tend for
your flu jab
if it's your first job you're asked to
stay
in the waiting room for a period of time
but subsequent ones you're allowed to
walk straight out the door following
your vaccinations so
so you know i do think it's a safe thing
for the government to have done but they
only made the announcement yesterday
afternoon so all our sites are having to
review their figures because that
significantly impacts on the flow they
can get through those sites
um so everything's being recalculated as
we speak and we will share it as soon as
we can
so we've got all of the primary care
network sites we've got all of the
existing pharmacy sites
all of which are going to be open for
longer periods of time with a greater
throughput so we do believe we'll be
able to meet meet the objective of those
four thousand a day
and we will share the details of how the
public can access that as soon as the
they have been finalized
um
so there is
a bit of a downside part of part of this
is that gps have been asked as sanji
javid said in the press uh sorry in the
house and has been confirmed
a great deal of detail on the
information that so far gps are allowed
to prioritize their time
to do the booster vaccinations so
they've been
advised they can and should defer
any non-urgent work
um until the new year
so there is a risk that the you know
availability of appointments for other
things at the gp practices
you know will be less
the details of that have still not come
out so you know i can't be very specific
but
um
you know i'll do my best to answer any
questions and we will be mostly we will
share that information again with the
public
because we need to ensure that those
expectations are
addressed openly and fairly from that
point of view
so
it's difficult for me to give you any
more specifics at this point in time
because it's been such a rapidly
changing program but i will do my best
to answer any questions you may have
thank you very much for that mark i have
a question from councillor new grosh
that's the new grush the androids
sorry i was stuck in the chat there
getting those specific figures thank you
very much for that um the first question
is how much of an increase is 4000 per
day to what we were delivering so what
was the naught baseline
and the second is i
at larkil it's a fantastic facility um
but with this massive rise i've noticed
in the last few days
thorley lane is getting blocked again
can i please ask um the last time this
happened you provided us a number of
no uh parking no waiting cones on one
side they've all since gone bar three
can i please ask that we have those
reinstated for this huge drive that's
going to block the village temple
village again um so those two things
thank you
so
um
we have
um
on our busiest days in the past
vaccinated over 2000 in a day
and because
the clinical staff associated with gp
practices are still going to be doing
some work
um during the core hours
then the the vision is that a lot of
these vaccinations will be offered at
weekends
under bank holidays
and evenings so out outside those core
hours there will be services from the
pharmacies and some services in the core
hours but um we've got the same risk has
just been discussed about all the other
um popular premises about we cannot
become
the location for spread so we need to we
need to actually vaccinate in a safe way
where we're not becoming the problem
rather than the solution
and
using all the facilities we've got in a
safe way to ensure that
does mean that you know we we are going
to have to be specific about the hours
that these are going to be available
because we don't want
cues outside general practice
when other routine work needs to happen
um as i work for health i can't promise
you the cones
however
we are absolutely aware of the people
management outside these venues
and a number of staff have been moved
off other routine tasks
um to be able to support
this larger vaccination and a large part
of that is managing the people outside
the buildings to ensure that that is
done in a safe manner so i would be very
surprised if they don't return when the
when the teams
are
you know out there doing this job better
from today i hope
so i hope that answers your questions
thank you uh mark uh mark about uh about
the management of these centers are we
actually short of
um and if anyone's listening and who
wants to volunteer how do they go about
it
um so
we we've we're very fortunate trafford
we have had a
very well motivated group of
existing clinicians and volunteers
who've supported the program um
the
the to increase that capacity we need to
increase you know the people management
the administration support and the
vaccinators
i haven't at this point got
the um
the details of how many vaccinators may
be needed where because all of that
information is being collated um at this
point in time um
volunteers in trafford we've been
collecting that information through a
lady called henrietta bottomley who's
been coordinating it
um and her email addresses is that
henrietta bottomly at nhs.net
and she's the point of con first point
of contact for us to be able to
coordinate
for the vaccinators for the clinical
vaccinators not for kind of support the
support each site is already linking
into the existing
volunteer network who
have been helping them with the
with the non-vaccinating tasks
thank you thanks mark i don't see any
further questions for you can i thank
you for the update that you've given
obviously it's a very fast moving
picture at the moment
thank you very much
which brings us to the next time the
agenda which is catherine o'connor on
community engagement welcome catherine
good morning all right can everyone hear
me
great um so actually just following on
from the previous item um our team also
look after community volunteers and so
i'll share our team link if anyone does
want to register in their community
and that's something that we also
coordinate and so you're welcome to come
through our route
and i'll share those details in the chat
and then we can also get them circulated
after the call
in terms of our general updates
and so some of the work that we've been
focusing on and has been around
unvaccinated people getting deeper
insight into their reasons for that
and we've had various different
fieldwork days i've updated on in the
past we've had community questionnaires
we've sent things out digitally and
we've also made some phone calls by the
practices and so that program of work is
now paused and we've had 119
results of those surveys come through
and our public health data team has done
some really useful crunching on that
data to pull out key insights and that's
being fed through and very proactively
into our programmes of work for
targeting those on vaccinated
communities
and as part of that we've made sure that
we've focused on some of the groups
where we know we have the biggest gap
and so that we can take insight for
people in the kind of um geographic or
demographic groups where we know
upstate's been limited to make sure
we've got that deeper knowledge of why
those reasons are and we're feeding that
through
and the key focus for us last week was
on omicron as i'm sure it was for most
of the teams on this call and so what
we've done as part of our role in that
is get out the messaging to our
community groups around how to keep
covered safe and a big push there
obviously is vaccination and the booster
program but then also the simple
messages that people are perhaps a
little tired of hearing but are still
very crucial for support things like
social distancing mask wearing
sanitizing and so we've been sharing
that to our networks and had a lot of
support from our partners there which
has been great that's gone through
people like the community hubs our
community champions mosques and other
faith groups the collective and the
wider vcsc
and we're also picking up on use of
digital screens in the community and so
some simple messaging for winter and at
various venues across trafford and again
things around code 19 safety and also
things such as keeping warm mental
health and support routes available
primarily channeling people to our
community pubs for that support over
winter
and as well as that we've assembled
winter well-being packs and so what that
is are some very practical items around
keeping warm and safe over winter
there's also a test kit involved in all
those packs and some leaflets again on
the supports available and how to keep
safe over winter
and so our team are assembling those at
the moment we've got all the different
elements that we're just putting them
together in a nice gift bag and then
we'll be delivering those um or working
with community groups to deliver them in
various areas of higher need and that
would be areas where there's inequality
and we know that our residents need that
extra bit of support and signposting
and so we'll be delivering that over the
coming
couple of weeks as well sort of ten days
time
um the big push links into what mark
jarvis was saying for the next few weeks
and so that's looking at how we can free
up a bit of additional capacity in our
team as well to support some of those
winter clinics for the booster
and we're having a big push on both our
own staff members but then also as i
mentioned at the start of my update we
do coordinate the volunteers and for
some of those clinics through our team
and so we're going out to our volunteers
and seeing where we can have some
additional capacity there too
in order to support that big effort
and so again as mark said we're kind of
a number crunching phase there of
looking quite rapidly at what can be
done over the next few days and weeks
and other work that's upcoming and we
have been facilitating a lot of focus
groups in the community as well
those are now um pretty much coming on
pause for christmas but we'll be
resuming in the new year but what that's
been is involving over 70 residents
getting their thoughts and experiences
on the impact of covid
from the previous year as well as
getting insight on specific issues so
things like for example second dose
hesitancy or children's vaccination or
boosters
and as i mentioned those groups are
pretty much on pause for christmas but
what we are doing is a bit of insight
crunching from that and pulling out some
key thematic analysis which will then be
feeding through to the relevant teams
that it applies to in order to make sure
that that insight in community
intelligence is embedded in our
approaches going forward
and as well as that general push on
vaccination
we're also still as a joint team looking
at equity i know that's key to some of
the work that jill is leading on just to
make sure that while we're pushing
volume we're also looking at
inequalities and making sure that some
of our communities where there are those
inequalities and have that enhanced
vaccination offering making sure we're
engaging in the right way there
and that's probably it for me for
general updates does anyone have any
questions
thank you catherine any questions for
catherine at all
catherine i don't see any so thank you
very much for that very thorough update
um it brings us virtue to the end of the
agenda
uh can i just say that we only actually
scheduled these meetings
to last for this year however in light
of the ongoing situation
uh we are going to continue with the
kobe 19 public engagement board i think
it's been a very very uh
good forum for getting our messages out
in trafford and keeping everybody
informed therefore our next meeting will
be on the 12th of january
2022
and will continue fortnightly thereafter
for the foreseeable future
i think
on ending this meeting this one i think
it's absolutely
vital that i thank environmental health
environmental protection our licensing
and regulatory services teams the ccg
for the vaccination rollout community
engagement our volunteer community
champions and our comm staff for getting
the messages out that they have this
year
it's been a
quite a roller coaster year and when we
thought i was thinking a few weeks ago
we were starting to come out of this but
clearly we're still in it and um
i i just i'll end up i'll just end by
wishing you all a very very happy
christmas and happy new year and let's
keep our fingers crossed that things
don't um
get as bad as as are being predicted
uh i think it's absolutely vital that
people do their very best in the
circumstances to enjoy christmas be with
their loved ones and take the advice the
very sound advice we've heard today from
our director of public health helen
collins thank you all very much indeed
for your attendance
thank you and
i